لم تبقى له حصون ولا مدن ولكن لا يعتقد
كثيرون هنا في شمال شرق سوريا ان تنظيم
داعش زاله يقولون انه باقي في مخيمات
والسجون وخلى نائمه ورحله البحث عنه لا
تبدا الا من مخيم الهول
[موسيقى]
الدخول لمخيم رهول السدعه التنقل في مركبه
مصفحه وحراسه مسلحين من قوات حمايه المخيم
وهؤلاء لا ينتشرون عاده داخل المخيم بل
يكتفون بمراقبه البوابات وتسير دوريات لكن
جوله كهذه تثير مخاوفهم من هجوم مسلح او
حتى بحجاره
[موسيقى]
53 الف شخص من 56 دوله يقطنون هنا
ويتوزعون على سته اقسام غالبيتهم من عائله
الدواعش قدمنا من الباغوز ومناطق اخرى
بدانا جولتنا من قسم المهاجرات والاسم
الذي يطلق على قسم زوجات الدواعش غير
السوريه او العراقيات واطفالهن به خيام
وسوق الملابس والخضر
من اين
تتحدثين قليلا
لم يكن الحديث مع الكثير منهن يسيرا رفضت
بعضهن الحديث
واخريات اعاقهن اللغه
متى اتيت الى هذا المخيم
الاقتراب من اخريات كان اسهل لكن الحديث
معهن كان ينعطف سريعا الى السماته في
الدفاع عن التنظيم
[موسيقى]
يعني هذا اوامر من خليفه جاءتنا
مجبرين
فيه خذنا مع امريكيه مع اخوان مجاهدين هل
انتم تطلع هناك ان شاء الله
طبقتم شرع الله
[موسيقى]
لا ترغب ام محمد وهكذا تسمي نفسها بالعوده
الى مصر فهي تعتقد انما تسميها دوره
الخلافه ستعود ترغبين بالعوده الى مصر
لكن اخريات ربما يئسنا ويامن فقط بان يعدن
لبلدانهم
[موسيقى]
اكيد اليوم قبل بكره
ندمتي على ذهابك هتسيب ضروري يعني لازم
نحن نرجع بلدنا ما يضلوا اوضاعنا هيك يعني
في
المخيم يعني انت شوفي يعني معروف الخيام
والوسخ وكل شيء يعني لازم يعني
ترحيل عائله داعش وتفكيك المخيم مسعا عبرت
عنه قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه التي طالبت
مرارا دولا باستلام رعاياها من عائله
التنظيم برايي الشخص انه اكثر من خمس سنين
او ست سنين احنا بحاجه لهم لحتى نفكك مخيم
الهول بالكامل لانه العدد كثير كبير العدد
ضخم انت عم تحكي عن 53 الف لاجئ ونازح
عندك العراقيين ما يقارب 27 الف عراقي
والسوريين اللي موجودين هن نسبتهم اكثر من
18 الف سوري اغلبيتهم هنن من مناطق سيطره
الحكومه السوريه
وعندك قسم خاص بالاجانب اللي هنن
المهاجرات او اذا بدك تخلي المخيم منهم
هنبيعها بحاجه لقرارات دوليه صارمه حتى
انت تقدري تفكي المخيم وترجعي كل هدول
لبلدانهم
مهمه صعبه اذا فيما اداره المخيم وتامينه
يبدوان اصعب
[موسيقى]
كان في حمله امنيه للقوات حمايه المخيم
داخل المخيم خلال الحمد لله الامنيه تنضبط
كميه كبيره من الاسلحه كمان تم القبض على
كثير من خلايا داعش
خطر بدا اوضح بعد اكتشاف شبكه خنادق
وانفاق محفوره تحت الارض لتهريب السلاح
ومتطرفين واموال صار بن عيشوبه العربيه
مخيم الهول في شمال شرق سوريا